hi I'm Seth Rogan I'm a
I'm Rose been told we must say the words
we are spilling the E.T you know a
little part of me died just there
[Music]
this is our third time working together
this is a little flirt oh like her mama
bet um
cool it's all going by so fast huh it's
crazy
can you believe she said we were
destructive no we're exactly the
opposite we are constructed
are we the next time Hanks and Meg Ryan
why do we work so well together
[Music]
I maybe hope that you are not the next
big Ryan
maybe she's chosen to maybe take a step
back from filmmaking and where is it I
don't think people don't want to lose
this gift
I can only that's a huge rolls to live
up to yeah can't be friends with a girl
there's lots of famous men and women
friends
Laura Dern and Sam Neal in Jurassic Park
Seth and Rose played husband and wife in
Neighbors one and two now they're just
friends in their new series platonic
streaming May 24th on Apple TV plus
think of this as a raunchy version of
When Harry Met Sally our characters in
platonic are best friends with no
benefits at all at all at all do you
think it's actually possible for men and
women to remain strictly platonic
friends and do you have many yourself of
course yes you're a platonic friend of
mine I have many platonic friends who
are women and men
um uh yeah I think uh yes of course
weirdo to not be able to be friends with
someone oh whoa what Will's getting a
divorce so call him we literally haven't
spoken to each other in years call him
that's what friends do your character is
going through a through a really bad
divorce
ment no your worst breakout story I got
dumped on my birthday
but you know who but yeah I brought I
had I I was dating
she broke up with me at the table and I
started crying
[Laughter]
okay
I got to dye your hair Platinum
Platinum Lauren think of that look and
is it true that blondes do have more fun
and what is the craziest thing you do
this is long
send me the invoice
it looked good and Lauren liked how it
looked but I think the subtext of a 40
year old man with bleached blonde hair
is sad and so I think that was that's
the conflict at play there is it it
looked good undeniable yeah everywhere I
went
it was a whole yeah it looked better
yeah everyone's like you look better
yeah but I was like and then but I let
it grow out and cut it off everyone's
like I thought you were gonna keep it I
was like I can't keep it are you insane
I'm 40.
I literally did that when I was 50. I
don't like feeling like the second most
important man in your life
oh Mark hunk Luke McFarland plays your
husband oh Mark I like that I love that
generation there which one of us was
your favorite on-screen husband I mean
yeah it's setting me up I know
oh God what am I supposed to say in here
and just the one clear that's your
defense
the defense rests
the grave
cautionary tale right a friend uh
who was dating they they broke up and to
make him feel better I like was like
I'll be honest she sucked and I never
liked her and I maybe said some
specifically more disparaging things
later than that and
um and then they got back together and
we're all hanging out and she's like hey
Seth I hear you didn't like oh no and I
literally turned to him and I'm like
what you you told her are you insane why
did you do that like The Brady Bunch I
know almost 10 years ago we still had
his husband and wife in the movie
Neighbors which one of us do you think
has changed the most in that time
[Laughter]
I'm gonna see you well you were pregnant
during the second neighbors with your
first child yes so you and now you have
18 children I'm not mistaken and so yeah
your life has changed significantly
exactly yeah
still got that uh family of yours you
want to see a photo
wow there they are cool
inflatonic my character will has zero
interest in your kids in real life would
you ever let me babysit your kids to
give you and Bobby a night out yes
whoever wrote this probably doesn't have
kids because the real truth if you have
kids you'll give your kids Daddy
I tricked two dogs already they're in
the back of my van
your bridesmaids co-star Melissa
McCarthy recently told E.T she would
never say no to a sequel I would do
anything with that group of women
there's just no way not to be like any
day anytime what about you would you
ever return for bridesmaids too
[Music]
as people have made a comedy and we
worked so hard and we like just got it
there
and like it's I'm very proud of
neighbors too but it was so hard to make
it
it's happening it's part of their terms
of service they want you to do it
get it yeah
yeah we go through some wild
ish we go through some wild stuff in
this series what was the wildest thing
that happened between takes
well we shot in uh downtown Los Angeles
a hot spot it was insane Insanity it was
probably like doing light
improvisational comedy literally there's
like four people trying to murder one
another girl like like 15 feet behind
you and you like hear it happen hey it's
creepy scars
[Music]
I was on the scooter once and my start
Mark was in like a pile of 400 broken
hair with eagles
[Music]
okay John apatel recently
baby from
from the 17. how old does that make you
feel would you ever make a sequel where
your teenage daughter gets knocked up
and you and Catherine our grandparents
oh that's a pretty good idea there you
go it's a pitch
I like that pitch she can be 17 now then
that actually whoa that actually works
it was a girl you know knowing because
it's Judd we shot both versions so it
takes me and of course we did because
uh we shot jokes for a daughter you know
you gotta leave your options
provides different different angles yes
it's a girl yeah
I remember there was a version where I
came back from the living room and said
to all my friends
it's got a dick that was a big joke and
I remember fighting for the boy just
because that joke was a big laugh yeah
thank you for joining us for spilling
the E.T still in the 18
. fun Rose got bangs
[Music]
[Laughter]
laughs